[Music]
what are you doing doing I'm practicing
I got an away game to go to
Oh away game for the war yeah well I got
something that might help you maximize
your experience at the airport
tell me more about that so today we were
talking about Google clouds IOT core
pushing airlines data into pub/sub data
flow and bigquery interesting so what
are you collecting and what are you
telling me about that so we're talking
about customer events data like you know
whether they check bags how much time
you have in between trips so that you
could possibly get a drink or upgrade
your seats
nice I would love that I spent a lot of
time at the airport yeah well hopefully
your data flow game is better than your
basketball game Wow whoa come on now all
right let's see it lets see it five
minute demo starting now
so before I jump into the actual demo I
just wanted to cover sort of the
architecture that will be representing
through this demo today we are
generating random data through compute
engine and feeding it into a pub sub
topic which we will then use cloud
dataflow to stream it into bigquery in
real-time let's go ahead and just jump
into the actual demo so the first thing
I want to show about how I got this set
up is I'm gonna head over to Google
Cloud storage which I mentioned is how
we did the device simulations and also
where we created some folders for our
data flow pipeline so we created a
bucket titled IOT Airlines v1 data we
created two folders within this bucket
and so that's going to include some
information about our device simulators
here and we've also created another
bucket for our data flow pipeline so for
our data flow pipeline we've also
included some files here and we created
two folders for staging and temp it
includes spinning up and shutting down
Google compute engine instances and they
access these GCS buckets for both IO and
temporaries file staging now we've also
set up a pub sub subscription so the
first thing we do here is head over to
pub sub and you see here we've created a
topic and this topic is titled airline
messages the type of subscription we
trade in under this topic is a pool
subscription and we've named it data
flow here so you can see here a
publisher application in this case would
be our IOT simulators they create a
topic in pub sub which we've titled
airline messages and that's a service
that sends messages to the topic now
going back a little bit I'm going to
show you IOT core because this is also
the component in which we register our
IOT simulators what we've done here is
we've registered this right here called
IOT Airlines registry we've essentially
cloned the git repository where we have
Java files and we've compiled the
application here uploaded a jar file to
the storage puppy that we showed earlier
this is our registry ID it's going to
accept in the form of MQTT and HTTP
protocols in the region us central one
we have pub/sub setup for this IOT
device registration which is the one we
created earlier airline messages any
time you register our device to connect
to IOT core and you just need a register
at first with cloud IOT it consists of
adding a device to a collection which is
this registry and
defining some of the essential
properties like we've done here the last
thing I'm going to show you is our
dataflow pipeline that we've created
what we've got to build this dataflow
pipeline is we've included SDK client
libraries for Java and Python plus rest
api s and we have essentially cloned the
git repository we've updated some files
there and then we deployed it directly
to dataflow here I'll show you here what
the pipeline we've prayed it looks like
so essentially it's reading messages
applying window and techniques for
streaming information from our ot
devices and it's creating a table row
and entity conversion so that we can
actually push it into other sources like
bigquery and datastore okay now that
we've had this whole pipeline set up
let's go ahead and to the last step and
show you what it looks like in terms of
the output in bigquery we have our data
event underscore data and this is where
all the data coming out of data flow
gets pushed into this table so we've
created a data set called IOT Airlines
v2 with our table events underscore data
and so you can see here this is what the
schema looks like it includes customer
ID the event type things like customer
name we also have you know how many bags
are checked how many seats are assigned
under their name how long the trip was
what the origin is at the destination
let's just do an example really quickly
of how we can compose a query on this
data set certain routes might be more
likely than others for certain upsells
like for example if somebody's flying
out at 6:00 in the morning on a Monday
maybe it's a business trip you can offer
them to buy Wi-Fi you can also upsell
them if customers carrying bags or has a
connecting flight for example maybe they
want to upgrade from Coach to first
class so let's go ahead and just do an
example query of just pulling customer
emails IDs and see if there's anybody
who has actually did a back check for
example so we can potentially upgrade
them so let's go ahead and open this I
have my example query here and you just
input it directly into this query box
here and run the query we were selecting
customer email ID from this data set and
table event underscore data and we're
looking for customers who have more than
one bag and the trip leg is more than
one you can see here this is just you
know fake generated data but in a real
case scenario and we might have a
different list of customers and their ID
so that we can immediately email them
and offer them another service well that
was amazing
thanks for sharing all that information
now I know when's the best time to get
up
because I'm tired of sitting in coach I
need to say first class all right well
here's to riding in style thanks again
everyone for watching take five with us
please comment like and subscribe below
[Music]